Dans les années 70, quand les gens ont commencé à y repenser,
ils ont dit : « Oui, évidemment qu’il y a des troubles du sommeil
chez les patients atteints de schizophrénie car ils sont sous l'influence d’anti-psychotiques.
Ce sont les anti-psychotiques qui causent les problèmes de sommeil. »
négligeant le fait que pendant les 100 ans qui précédèrent,
des troubles du sommeil avaient été constatés, bien avant l’existence des anti-psychotiques.
Alors que se passe-t-il ?
Beaucoup de groupes étudient
les maladies comme la dépression, la schizophrénie et le trouble bipolaire,
et ce qui se passe au niveau des troubles du sommeil.
Il y a une grande étude que nous avons publiée l'année dernière au sujet de la schizophrénie,
les données sont vraiment incroyables.
Les individus schizophrènes
sont la plupart du temps éveillés pendant la nuit
et endormis pendant la journée.
D'autres groupes ont montré l’absence totale de rythme circadien.
Leur sommeil était réduit à néant.
Certains n’avaient aucune capacité à réguler leur sommeil par le cycle lumière-obscurité.
Ils se levaient de plus en plus tard
chaque nuit. Le sommeil était anéanti.
Alors, que se passe-t-il ?
La très grande nouvelle est que
la maladie mentale et le sommeil ne sont simplement pas associés
mais qu'ils sont liés physiquement dans le cerveau.
Le réseau neuronal qui prédispose au sommeil normal,
procure un sommeil normal, et celui qui assure
une santé mentale normale se chevauchent.
Et qu'est-ce qui démontre cela ?
Eh bien, des gènes qu’on sait être très importants
dans la production du sommeil normal,
une fois mutés,
prédisposent également les individus aux problèmes de la santé mentale.
L'année passée, nous avons publié une étude
qui a démontré qu'un gène qui était lié à la schizophrénie,
une fois qu’il subit une mutation, détruit aussi le sommeil.
Par conséquent, nous avons la preuve d'un chevauchement mécanique véritable
entre ces deux systèmes importants.
D'autres études ont découlé de ces recherches.
La première a montré qu'en fait, les troubles du sommeil précèdent
certains types de maladies mentales,
et nous avons démontré que les jeunes
qui sont susceptibles de développer un trouble bipolaire,
ont déjà une anomalie du sommeil
avant qu'un trouble bipolaire ne puisse être diagnostiqué.
L'autre observation était que les troubles du sommeil
peuvent en fait exacerber,
aggraver l'état de la maladie mentale.
Ma collègue Dan Freeman a utilisé une variété d'agents
qui ont stabilisé le sommeil et réduit le degré de paranoïa
chez ces individus à 50%.
Alors, qu'est-ce que nous avons?
Nous avons, sous la forme de ces connexions, certaines choses vraiment passionnantes.
Du point de vue de la neuroscience, en comprenant
la neuroscience de ces deux systèmes,
nous commençons à comprendre comment le sommeil
et la maladie mentale sont produits et régulés dans le cerveau.
Le deuxième aspect est que, si nous pouvons utiliser le sommeil
et les interruptions de sommeil comme un signal d'avertissement précoce,
alors nous avons l'opportunité de faire quelque chose.
Si nous savons que ces individus sont vulnérables,
une intervention très tôt devient possible.
La troisième chose, qui est la plus enthousiasmante selon moi,
est que nous pouvons considérer les centres de sommeil dans le cerveau
comme une nouvelle cible thérapeutique.
En stabilisant le sommeil chez ces individus qui sont vulnérables,
nous pouvons certainement les aider à retrouver une bonne santé,
mais aussi soulager un peu des symptômes consternants de la maladie mentale.
Alors, laissez-moi conclure.
J'ai commencé en disant de prendre le sommeil au sérieux.
Nos attitudes vis-à-vis du sommeil sont tellement différentes
de ce qu’elles étaient à l'époque préindustrielle,
quand nous étions souvent enveloppés dans nos couettes.
Nous comprenions alors intuitivement l'importance du sommeil.
Ceci n'est pas une sorte de préchi-précha.
C'est un moyen pragmatique pour s’assurer une bonne santé.
Si vous dormez bien, cela améliore votre concentration,
votre attention, votre jugement, votre créativité, votre sociabilité, votre santé.
Si vous dormez, cela réduit vos sautes d'humeur, votre stress,
votre niveau de colère, votre impulsivité,
et votre propension à boire et à vous droguer.
Nous finirons en disant
qu’une compréhension de la neuroscience de sommeil
est vraiment en train de changer comment nous voyons
certaines des causes de la maladie mentale,
et nous apporte de nouvelles solutions
pour traiter ces maladies incroyablement débilitantes.
Jim Butcher, l'auteur de livres d'heroic fantasy, a dit,
« Le sommeil est Dieu. Adorez-le. »
Je ne peux que vous recommander de faire de même.
Merci pour votre attention.
(Applaudissements)